-You look fantastic.
I'm so happy you're here.
I can't even -- I'm not
even sure if I can tell you
how much I enjoyed
your performance.
You were mind-blowingly genius
in "Sweeney Todd."
Really unbelievable.
You were fantastic.
-Thank you.
-And I know --
Not only the comedy was great,
but also your dramatic acting.
Your singing was beautiful.
It made people cry,
including me.
But you made me laugh.
But also the accent you --
-Thank you.
[British accent] Thank you.
Thank you very much.
-Wow! That's what I'm talking
about. That's all I want.
Now I get to hear
your real voice.
Let's talk about this later.
I want to talk about the family.
I want to know more about you.
I know -- How old is your son?
-[Normal voice]
Oh, he just turned 7,
which is crazy, bananas.
-Seven.
-Seven. You know, seven.
It's a fun one. It's a fun age.
-Is he into Halloween?
-Super, super into Halloween.
He wanted to be Marty McFly.
I mean, so good, right?
-I would love that.
-Me too.
But nobody at school
knew who Marty McFly was?
I mean, come on. What are they
thinking, these 7-year-olds?
-They're not ready for
"Back to the Future" yet.
But get ready.
It's a great movie.
-Right? Can't wait.
-They're going to love it.
-I was going to be Doc. I was
very excited about the wig.
-That would have been fantastic.
-I know,
but then he changed his mind.
Then he was gonna be, like,
a werewolf from "Goosebumps."
And then we finally
settled on Beetlejuice,
which I feel really good about.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Classic.
-He loves "Beetlejuice"?
-Loves "Beetlejuice,"
but he also has
a really special love
for Michael Keaton.
-Yes!
-Right?
-That's a good --
That's a good guy to love.
-I feel like
I'm raising him right.
He's very concerned about
what Michael Keaton is doing,
how he is.
He wants to meet him very badly.
So, Michael Keaton,
if you're listening,
my son would like
to meet you someday.
-Oh, he's a great guy to meet.
-I mean, the best.
Yeah, he's really fun. Wait.
I love -- He just is interested
in the actor Michael Keaton?
-Yes. Because Michael Keaton
was also Batman.
So he's --
You know, Michael Keaton.
Batman. Beetlejuice.
It's really, really, like,
an exciting time
in Michael Keaton's career.
-Yeah.
And so your son
has a Beetlejuice costume?
-Yes, yes.
He was very insistent
that there was also
some male pattern baldness
involved in the wig.
It's good.
-Here's a sneak peek
of what you'll see
tomorrow on Halloween
walking the streets.
-Tomorrow! Yeah.
-Little guy running around.
-Look at that. Really good.
[ Laughter ]
-Stop it. He is so cute.
-So good. Yeah.
Next year, he's gonna
be Birdman. It's great.
-Oh. He's so cute. Now, you --
Were you a funny kid, too,
just like your son?
-Well, you know,
I liked funny things.
I loved --
I love "The Carol Burnett Show."
And I loved "Golden Girls"
and I loved "SNL."
I was a big, big "SNL" kid.
I also --
I loved "The Tonight Show."
I used to watch it
with my grandpa.
So this is like --
kind of like -- I had the feels.
I was like,
"I'm making my debut!"
-Yes. You're making a debut.
Exactly.
For grandpa.
-For my grandpa.
-We love you, Grandpa. Come on.
-I know.
Also, why was he letting me
watch that late at night?
-And "Saturday Night Live, too."
-I know.
-I had those parents, as well.
They would let me watch
"The Tonight Show."
I go, "Can I just stay up
to watch Johnny's monologue?"
-Uh! Me too! Yeah. The best.
And then I also was very,
very interested
in Barbra Streisand's skin
because I thought it --
it must be like "buttah."
It had to be like buttah.
-Oh, my gawsh.
-I was very into the --
-"Coffee Tawk."
"Coffee Tawk."
Very into "Coffee Talk."
And the Church Lady.
Those were, like, my two bits
that I did at parties.
From the ages of like 4 to 7,
that was, like, my bit.
-You said that you're not
very good at taking headshots.
-No.
-And I go, "What do you mean?"
You go, "Well, I'll bring you
two just to show you examples."
Now, this is your
first headshot, right?
-Yeah.
This is, like, when I was 14,
but I look like a woman.
I look like a weird woman.
Like, why?
-You were 14 years old?
-Yeah, I know I look older there
than I do now.
It's very uncomfortable.
-Wow. I mean, very glamorous.
-So much hair, too.
I mean, big hair.
There's a lot going on.
And then there was just a series
of bad headshots
when I was a kid.
Like, this one summer --
You know when Sun-In came out?
-[ Gasps ]
-It was the thing.
It was the thing.
-I did Sun-In.
-You did, too? It's so good.
-Yeah, my sister had it.
And I was like,
"Well, let me just try it."
And then it turns
your hair orange.
-Oh, yeah.
Full-blown white for me.
I was like -- Ohh.
I was very platinum blond.
-[ Laughs ] "Ohh."
-It worked.
-I like that character.
I was like, "Ohh!"
-"Ohh. I was so ohh.
I was like, "I'm going
to Lake Powell
and using my Sun-In. Ohh."
It was so, so much.
And it worked.
[ Applause ]
So that was, like, July.
And then by October,
I had a full 3 inches of root,
and it was time
to take my new headshots,
and this is what happened.
[ Audience groans ]
[ Laughter ]
-Come on. That's so cute.
-You hear that audience
reaction?
It's like,
"Oh. I'm sorry for you."
-Come on. That's so cute.
-I don't think
I've really ever shared this.
It's really -- This takes
a lot of balls to share.
Also my eyebrows. I needed
to get my eyebrows plucked.
-What are you talking about?
You're adorable!
Are you kidding me?
-It's a lot.
-Well, look at this. This --
This kid grows up
to be in "Sweeney Todd."
[ Cheers and applause ]
And crushing it.
Amazing performance.
The story is pretty dark,
but there are
a lot of funny parts.
And, again,
you going down the stairs --
There's this physical thing.
I'm not spoiling it
because, if you can,
run and go see this because --
January 14th?
-You got it.
-You're leaving.
-Yeah, yeah.
Me and Josh Groban. Sweet
Josh Groban. Who's brilliant.
-You're great together.
You're so great.
You're both going.
-We're both going. Yeah.
-Are you -- Are you sad?
It is bittersweet?
Or is it after you've done
250 performances,
you're like, "Yeah..."
-I mean, it's been one of
the most humbling blessings
of my career,
getting to play this part.
I grew up loving Angela Lansbury
so much that I used to just say
I want to be her
when I grow up, you know?
And then I kind of got to be
for the last year.
So it's been such a blessing.
But I'm, you know,
gonna miss it.
-But Angela Lansbury,
Patti LuPone
have done this role,
and now you...
-Talk about those shoes.
-Yeah. I know.
Talk about those shoes to fill.
And you filled it very well,
by the way.
You have a picture
that you took. You did "Wicked"?
-I did "Wicked" many moons ago.
They're actually --
They're having
their 20th anniversary today.
Can you believe that?
All those witches! Yes.
I was -- I was a witch
many, many, many moons ago
when I was younger,
but on my last performance,
there's this incredible poster
of Angela Lansbury
when she did "Sweeney Todd"
at that same theater.
And I said -- [ Gasps ]
"I need to take a picture
with Angela Lansbury, please,
please, as Mrs. Lovett."
And then we got this picture.
So that was like 18 years ago.
17 years ago.
-And look at you.
And now you're playing...
-That's me and Mrs. Lovett.
-You're playing Mrs. Lovett.
-It's kind of bananas.
-When you -- When you do --
When you play this role,
do you go like,
"I have a take on this,"
or do you go,
"Can I be funny in this thing"?
-No. You just pray. You pray.
-You pray. You go...
-You pray.
And then you go to the script
and you say,
"What does she want?
How is she going to get it?
And who am I talking to?"
You know, you just go
to the basics.
And then all those years
of "Nick at Nite" and "SNL,"
they kind of seep in, too,
and they just all
kind of meld together.
You know. I don't know.
-In the first maybe 10 seconds
that I'm watching you,
you, like, fly --
flop into this thing, and I go,
"Oh, my gosh!"
Like, do you have bruises
and everything everywhere?
-Yes.
-You do?
-They're all covered up
right now.
No. Yeah.
You know, I wear a shin guard.
I've got some really sensible
padding in my skirts.
But, you know, a good bruise
or two means you did it right.
-Oh, my God. No.
But, I mean,
you're un-un-unbelievable.
You have to.
You're gonna miss it, right?
-Oh, of course. Yeah.
There's this incredible lyric
in the show that, you know --
Stephen Sondheim, one of the
greatest ever to have lived.
He said, "Slow, love, slow.
Time's So fast.
Now goes quickly.
See, now it's past.
Soon will come. Soon will last.
Wait."
And it means
just stay in the moment.
Because we're so blessed
to be here.
-You are unbelievable, pal.
Come back whenever you want.
-You're the best.
-You have to. I love you.
Annaleigh Ashford.
"Sweeney Todd" is now playing
at the Lunt-Fontanne Theatre.
We'll be right back
with stand-up from Jesus Trejo.
Stick around, everybody!